hi um i'm louis metzger and
i really thank you for the opportunity
tonight i'm going to talk about
how our future drugs will come from the
oceans and hopefully make for you
a selfish case for protecting ocean
biodiversity
so this biodiversity is threatened by
everything from coral bleaching
to plastic accumulation to the mining of
seabed
metal nodules to things like the oil
spill that recently happened in
mauritius
evolved chemistry in the oceans and
elsewhere is one of humanity's greatest
assets
whether it be sponges that make
potentially anti-cancer compounds
or enzymes that have evolved to do green
chemistry
so nature's chemistry is encoded by dna
so
organisms via their dna rna and proteins
encode chemistry and this chemistry
evolves with the organism
and ocean organisms encode their own
chemistry
fewer than 90 of ocean species have even
been identified
and far fewer of that have been
carefully characterized
so what sort of drugs might lurk in the
deep and what sorts of molecules might
white
might we lose if we lose species
diversity
a good example would be compounds from
cone snail venom here a cone snail is
stunning a fish
as it envelops it with its stomach this
venom
has evolved over deep time in cone
snails
and one of these venom components has
been used to make a non-opioid pain drug
called zucconetide and if you look at
the three-dimensional
rendering on the far right of the slide
you'll see that this is a very shapely
molecule
more on that later
helichondrin b this elaborate molecule
isolated from a sponge
was used to make the drug arabulin this
is a treatment for metastatic breast
cancer
it's been successful
fucoidins are molecules that have
recently been shown from brown algae
to inhibit star's cove ii viral entry
into
mammalian cells in the laboratory so
this might be a starting point for
therapeutics
alginates are polymers that are found in
algae that are used traditionally in
wound dressings
but they're now being used as scaffolds
to grow new cells for regenerative
medicine
sponges inspired nucleoside analogs that
were used
to develop drugs azt the first
effective hiv therapy was derived from
these nucleoside analogues
as is vela cyclobur used for herpes
nucleoside analogs from sponges also led
to the development
of cetera being and this is a drug that
was a game changer in the treatment of
certain types of leukemia
really increasing survival rates
cycle cyclomarines are anti-infectives
discovered from an ocean bacterium in
the bahamas
and some types of them seem to kill the
bacteria that causes tuberculosis
others target a parasite causing malaria
rampamiocene was discovered in coastal
soil on easter island
originally it was anti-fungal but it's
now a very important drug for
immunosuppressant
anti-rejection drugs and it's used to
prevent organ rejection and transplant
patients
so the ocean has many gradients
temperature light nutrients salinity
gases pressure and more
and these act upon the organisms that
live there over deep time
to result in really unique chemistry
and the evolution of organisms i should
emphasize is evolution of chemistry
dna via rna via proteins encodes
chemistry
and as organisms evolve their chemistry
evolves and the reproduction of the
conditions of this evolution is
difficult
nature's chemistry is special because it
natural molecules have handedness
acetaminophen doesn't but rifampicin on
the right
with the hatch marks shows points of
handedness
and this handedness leads to shapeliness
so rifampicin
is shown in red rendered in a
space-filling model
because of these points of handedness it
fits into an enzyme that is a drug
target
shown in blue and this is a feature of
natural drugs
so many of these natural compounds are
the type of compounds that a medicinal
chemist wouldn't dream of
but have evolved in nature and if we
lose species diversity we lose chemistry
that we won't rediscover
so my takeaway is the oceans contain
medicinal treasures
that evolved in deep time and under
unique conditions and once lost they may
never be rediscovered
so preserving biodiversity is really
self-preservation
thank you for your time
thank you louis and where do you see
uh medicine you know if we lose the
ocean
well i mean it's it's an enormous source
of biodiversity
certainly there is a biodiversity on
land but we need
uh every molecular handle we can get to
discover new drugs especially for
anti-infectives
so it would be it would be very tragic
and it's hard to put a price on that